Hello Freak bitches.
So I was big on surfing and in the first month or so that I was in Hawaii,
I went to the apple store in Honolulu and uh,
I met one of my favorite surfers of all time.
I got called Kalani,
rob,
and when I was playing Kelly Slater's pro surfing game,
I would always pick Kalani because he did the most radical moves,
you know,
so I'm in the apple store,
he's there with his boys.
I was like,
shit,
that's Kalani Romp.
And then he comes up to me,
he's like,
dude,
you're that guy in load the rings.
I was like,
Oh shit,
it's on now.
So I was like,
you're Kalani,
rob.
I was like,
I'm here for like nine months,
can you help me out surfing?
And he was like,
yeah,
we're going to go the no show now.
So I came with him,
whoa.
Hung out.
Uh,
and we became really tight.
So a huge story for a wife.
For me it was getting to know Kalani.
I mean he taught me into waves.
I had no business being involved in.
There's a place called go island on the north shore,
which is a heavy wave and you have to paddle out to an island,
walk across the island because then you're going to miss the break and then
paddle out past the break.
There's no concept of you're paddling out through the break because it's so big.
So as we Kalani and a few of his mates and we were all getting ready and he came
up to me,
he was like,
okay,
this is the most hectic wave I'm ever going to take you into.
Stay close to me.
If you need help,
let me know.
Don't fuck around because it can kill you.
And don't go left.
Go right.
No,
no,
don't go right.
Go left because going appeal left.
But if you go right,
you're in the braking zone and you're fucked.
I was like,
alright,
cool.
So fucking terrible story coming up.
So we.
So we paddle out and I'm having fun and I'm watching everyone in the lineup.
I'm about 10 feet away from the drop zone,
so I'm able to like sit there on the wave and watch people like or the side.
I'm like,
alright,
cool.
I got this fast,
I'm going to,
I'm going to take it.
So I paddled out battle.
That battle wave picked me up big like oh shit,
super powerful drops me and I really try and go left.
I like cut the board and then try and go left.
But it's so powerful because breaking here on my left that it spits me to the
rife.
I'm fully aware that it's about me to the right.
So I'm like,
Okay Shit,
I'm just going to wipe out,
take a big breath and paddle out.
So I wipe out.
I go on to come up and as is usually the case with surfing,
anything above overhead when you come up that wave's coming for you against what
you have to do is take a huge breath,
go under and it's the next time you come up you can make progress because you're
out breath,
you disoriented.
I do that and Joe,
I just can't.
I can never catch a break,
so I go under,
thrown around by the washing machine,
come up the thing.
Okay,
get on your board,
start paddling,
look ways,
right.
They're like,
oh,
go and drink and hold my breath.
Come up again.
And I'm trying to time it so that I can get it.
I just getting pounded,
pounded,
pounded.
And at one point I see Kalani paddling over to me.
I'm like,
all right,
cool.
We're going to be okay.
So Kalani comes up to me and he's like mad,
like I've never really heard him.
You mad before?
He's like,
Dude,
get on your board and go that way.
I'm like,
okay,
that's what I've been trying to do for like 10 minutes.
But so now he's behind me.
He's paddling,
I'm paddling,
he's pushing me,
paddling,
pushing me,
paddling like fucking superman.
And we eventually get out past the break.
So he's like,
all right,
you're going to sit here for 20 minutes and then when I'm done you're going to
paddle in with me safe.
And I was like,
okay,
fine.
I got it.
So when we come in,
he's like,
the reason why I came in to get you,
it was not only were you in the drop zone but you were like completely lacking
of any color on your face.
And he was like,
people in the line,
it was saying,
dude,
go get your boy because he's in trouble.
And I was like,
I was handling it.
I was definitely out of breath and a little fucked up.
But he's a wharton then.
So he was like,
no,
eight more waves on your headlight that you wouldn't have had the strength to
fight past the wave and get up here because you get these little gasps in there.
Dude,
it's so heavy and it has a really good trick.
Colone told me this one.
He's like,
if you're under the water and you rolling around and you're fucked and you need
to take a breath,
drink the tiniest amount of seawater.
Tiny sip.
Just go like that.
Tricks your body into thinking you took a breath and it will give you an extra
five seconds.
So because you've just taken an in will,
not an inhalation,
but you've,
you've put something in your body so your lungs are like,
okay,
we can chill.
The panic goes for a little bit.
Yeah.
A lot of the girls I grew up around,
uh,
they,
they had to maintain their virginity for marriage.
So a lot of them took in the.
But yes.
Paula,
lot of butts I guess.
Did you know,
is that really true?
That's what they were doing.
Well,
the,
yeah,
the one girl that I was pretty close with,
she was 18 years old.
I was 13 and like we hung out a lot when you take the bus to the beach from the
valley and smoked cigarettes and uh,
yeah,
she took it in the but
she was five years old and new.
That's it's one thing if you're 30 and she's 35,
that's totally normal.
Sure.
But 15 and 18,
that's a fucking 13.
I was 13.
Fifteen,
13 and 18.
Yeah,
that's a giant gap.
A Jeff five years is a giant five years is.
And I think part of that is she was so sheltered,
she'd grown up in such a strict Persian family that maybe mentally she was 13.
You know what I mean?
Like I taught her to smoke cigarettes and stuff.
Whoa.
You told her?
Yeah.
She was real sheltered.
Jesus shed like we take the bus to the beach and she would have to stop at a
payphone every hour to call her dad and check in.
That's how strict they were.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's pretty.
Wow.
Wonder what happened?
What was her rationale?
Well,
probably my buddy's buddy.
How many times did you take in the ass for everything breaks down.
You're driving off road with a car that's not designed for it.
It's like you got the wrong direction on that vehicle.
Do you understand?
It's an.
I don't,
I've never,
you know,
honestly,
it's never been about this
with reasonably good reason.
It's,
it's chocolate.
There's a lot of wrong.
I mean she,
first of all,
it be a lot of clean up pre and post.
Yeah.
But second of all this girl,
what was her rationale to maintain purity?
And that's a very common thing.
And like,
how did she explained it though,
that I have to be married a virgin,
that my father,
they checked the bedsheets on your wedding night and eat you out if you're a
person
and then he can tell.
That's right Tom.
Exactly how it went.
Yeah.
Normal.
He finishes up and he's like,
yeah,
you're still good.
So it's a little bloody
fucking Christ Jesus Christ.
It's so crazy.
So when she explained it to where you like at 13,
you're probably.
Wait what I mean,
but in the book,
I mean,
it's like I knew about sex was.
I mean I was at,
I wasn't doing anything.
I mean I was getting my ass fingers.
I was 13.
I was very,
you know,
an experience.
I was just blown away.
And uh,
and uh,
she was so funny.
This is so a memory I have of her.
I was wearing a tank top and it was summertime and I remember she poked my
armpit fat and she goes,
Ooh girl,
you got to have big tvs where you grow up arm,
fat,
fatty,
and I in La.
She was right.
Yeah,
I was armpit fat.
That's hilarious.
I just,
I thought that it was,
it was bizarre,
but she explained that it was a religious thing and this was to maintain her
purity.
God wants her to take in the but God wants you to do anal
and then you come out of it and you slowly come out of it and you were like
noise canceling headphones.
I'm just in a doctor's office like in a weird,
not even weird like those like 19 seventies doctors' offices that you see in la,
like just sort of a shitty elevator and whatever.
So when I came out of the first one I was like,
it was rough because I didn't know I was going to trip like that and b,
I had been.
I didn't get a ton of sleep the night before and so I was.
And I'd flown that day.
I was just kind of groggy and,
and I felt really shitty and it took me like I was like,
after I was done,
I probably laid in the bed there for like an hour.
So it was like,
I can't do shit right now.
Like I can't,
I could barely stand.
So the first day was rough and uh,
and that I still felt shitty that night.
I was like,
I don't think I'm going to do it again.
Like,
that was too rough.
And um,
then I woke up Tuesday morning and felt fucking great.
I was like,
oh,
um,
I got to do it again,
felt great.
Like I felt clear.
Here's the,
one of the ways my
depression manifested itself was like,
I felt
my head felt heavy and I felt like I had like,
I had like a weight on my forehead,
you know,
that's the way I felt when I did ecstasy the day after,
the day after.
I felt it felt amazing when I did that.
And that's what it is because it depletes.
Yeah,
yeah.
All the Serotonin's gun.
Yeah.
And that's basically what people with depression a lot of times are like,
just everyday isn't just like a headwind.
It's not,
it's just like fucking,
could this be a little bit easier?
Like I'm not asking for a miracle and just like I'm just sick of having to walk
into the wind all the time,
a little bit uphill into the wind.
Like,
fuck all right.